welcome back to new rockstars this is
the big question the show that gives you
too much information about why you
shouldn't be scrolling your family's
photo albums like their freaking tinder
profiles your nasties
my name's mt and i'm here today with my
fellow big head gang brother tommy
bechtold what's going on tommy whoo big
head gang let me hear you
how's that big head doing together
brother dude seven and three quarters or
don't even talk to me okay that's all
i'm talking you got your your right your
hat size
seven and a half you're there but if
you're any lower than that you're not in
the big head gang you're in the normal
head gang and that's fine but you're
always all be part of the boo thing all
right you're all welcome in the booth
hank gang i dig it i love it i'm glad
your big head is looking very beautiful
today
very nice yes but hit me with that big
question tommy what is today's big
question let's go baby we've talked a
lot about the loki series on the big
question and on this channel as a whole
so much has changed or expanded in the
mcu because of this show and we know the
future is going to be even more crazy
but there's one question from the loki
series that we've
been avoiding and now is the time for us
to address it peaches and cream is here
to
uh sort through all sorts of awkward
feelings uh it's a question a lot of
people have been asking for so here it
is this week's big question is what the
romantic pairing of loki and sylvie be
considered incest
[Laughter]
yeah we gotta talk about it because you
know i mean we're gonna try to be as
scientific about this question as we can
because this topic likely gives most
people the heebie-jeebies as it should
but we all were kind of left wondering
this question when the episode ended
because it was kind of weird like when
they first started flirting with the
series i was just like what what are
they doing here are they is loki about
to like kiss himself like what's going
to happen yeah that's what happened so
what's this incest let's let's dig into
it but to begin we have to first
establish what incest even is because
incest is considered to be the human
sexual activity between close family
members or relatives and i mean no duh
i'm sure we all sort of knew that but
just to lay it down like clearly and
generally these are people so closely
related that they are forbidden by law
to marry and obviously laws vary from
place to place unfortunately um and in
some instances people are free to marry
relatives such as cousins which is kind
of weird but yeah i guess
whatever
[Music]
but for the purposes of this very very
scientific discussion we're going to
consider the persons who are blood
relatives aka people in sanguinuity as
they say
basically don't have sex with first
degree relatives it's just a general
rule as i like to call it rule number
one don't have sex with general with
first degree relatives which are
individuals who share 50 of your genes
like parents children siblings oh my god
just don't do it just generally the fact
that we're making this disclaimer is
terrifying who's watching this
the lannisters we're gonna get eve like
angry comments from the incest community
like hold on this is intolerant i can't
believe it wait a minute so you're
saying i can only be stuck in washing
machines and have my step bro make love
to me i can't have my real bro make love
to me
the term incest was first used back in
the 13th century as it's one of the
oldest cultural taboos
as it should be and most modern
societies have laws prohibiting
incestuous marriages and the practice is
generally shunned in cultures throughout
history unless you're royalty for some
reason because then it's weirdly
encouraged
because apparently you got to keep that
bloodline extra like strong sick
keep that bloodline sick keep those eyes
close together keep the bloodline thick
that's what you gotta do
[Laughter]
okay but why exactly is incest so
discouraged like what is it about incest
that makes incest bad well to answer
that it just is so don't even like i
don't want to hear it just don't yeah
okay at the end we're not your
babysitters but if we were that wouldn't
be incest that would be something worse
it wouldn't be incest you know as long
as you were if we were babysitting you
over 18. yeah totally fine with me i
think that's just a service you can get
in vegas
[Laughter]
but no no we're gonna be as adult as
serious as we can be and as we talk
about this weird ass issue because you
know i personally blame game of thrones
for all of this because
everything was fine before game of
thrones made incest cool soiled it
soiled it soiled it the lannisters those
dirty lannisters yeah like i don't
understand like they're really
attractive people like the lannisters
are very attractive human beings you
could have anybody in the world why your
brother slash sister i mean let's think
about it
they're good looking they're powerful
they pay their debts on time
why will they not just have sex with
people that aren't blood relatives
they're everything i'm looking for
i think you probably just uh hit the
nail on the head there because they're
not gonna find anyone as perfect as them
so they're probably just like you know
what no one pays their bills on time
like us i've gotta bone you sister we
did say we'd take this seriously
all right okay so besides the obvious
societal issues of family copulation
there is a scientific and evolutionary
reason why incest is not a good idea
one reason why incest is prohibited is
to prevent inbreeding which can result
in a ton of genetic disorders in
offspring when the parents share a close
genetic relationship the children can be
at a greater risk for congenital
disorders death and developmental and
physical disability so like your genes
if you are like super super close to
like in in um similarity you're gonna
have a lot of problems there so uh
no no no no no no so incest is not
healthy for the survival of the species
while loki and sylvie kissing may have
destroyed the fabric of the universe
itself it did not produce any offspring
so at least we're safe there and thank
god that didn't happen because i'm
pretty sure loki was kissing without a
condom on so anything could have
happened there that's a big no no my my
life if you kiss a girl you can get her
pregnant you learn to dear first that's
what we're doing we're teaching you the
real this is sex education never kiss a
girl because you will get pregnant and
die that's why i've never kissed a girl
at all my 29 years of just kidding
that's not true
oh i was gonna say me either but all
right i guess i'm also kidding
but luckily kate herron the director of
loki actually weighed in on this big
question because during a recent
interview with polygon kate said my
interpretation of it is that they're
both loki's but they aren't the same
person like i don't see them as being
like brother and sister they have
completely different backgrounds and i
think that that's really important to
their character they sort of have the
same role in terms of the universe and
destiny but they won't make the same
decision so the director says that it's
not incest alright
and sophia di martino the actor who
plays loki or sylvie commented on this
romance as well and she said i kind of
expected it to be pretty split and some
people to be really into it and just
going along with it for the fact that
it's a sort of love story and then i
knew that there would be some skeptical
people who weren't sure for me it's kind
of an exploration of self-love it's not
as straightforward as two people falling
for each other or versions of the same
thing it was important to us that she
was a different character and that she
had her own way of talking and fighting
and reacting so there we have two people
very involved with the situation and
characters who confirmed that loki and
sylvie hooking up isn't incest but
that's not enough so let us go into what
the science behind incest even is so an
important thing to think about here is
dna we're going to have to base all of
our discussion on human dna because
human dna is presumably different from
asgardian or frost giant dna but we
don't have any research available on
that so we're just working with what we
got and as guardians and frost giants
are both bipedal humanoid creatures so
the dna is probably somewhat similar to
some degree but what is dna well i'm
glad you asked because dna or
deoxyribonucleic acid deoxyribonucleic
acid what
deoxyribonucleic acid is our molecular
blueprint it's those tiny little double
helix chains you probably learned about
from that cute little cartoon in
jurassic park because that's literally
where they unveiled dna research that's
when they first discovered it the
jurassic park one um most dna resides
inside the nucleus of the cells in our
body and one thing that dna does is
create rna which is used as a road map
for the arrangement of amino acids in
our body so from the dna comes the human
body it's all science it's basically the
code that makes our bodies write it make
itself but dna also makes up our genes
and every human has between twenty
thousand and twenty five thousand genes
so god if you thought you had like a lot
of genes in your closet not not as much
as a gene in your body i'm just saying
pretty sure no one's made that joke
before it's in your
they weren't talking about your pants
each person has two copies of each gene
one from each of our parents and most
people share the same genes but a tiny
percentage of our genes less than like
one percent are slightly different from
other humans and it's these differences
in genes that give each human unique
characteristics and features so dna
determines what we will look like along
with a host of other biological and
physical factors so since loki and silvi
appear to be so physically different
there is no way that their dna could be
identical so if we were talking about
loki and president loki then we might be
looking at a much closer dna match there
so with loki and sylvie their dna makeup
just is so probably so different from
each other that i don't think they would
make much of a difference so what do we
know about sylvie and loki's biological
makeup well let's start with sylvie
because ladies first because we're nice
men here we're men of class gentlemen
big head gang gentleman gay one thing
about the big head gang is we are ladies
first let's start with silvia she's much
older than loki i mean not to be mean i
mean just just a fact and we see on a
form in the tva her full name is sylvie
laffy daughter so much like loki in
sylvie's timeline she is also the
offspring of a frost giant lauffy and we
can assume that laufey is also the king
of the frost giants of myotinine in
sylvie's universe because why would odin
bother adopting the offspring of some
random frost giant who we also randomly
bothered to learn the name of so we know
that both sylvie and loki had laufey as
a father but what about their mothers
because we never learn about loki's
biological mother in the mcu so we have
no answers there but in the comics
loki's mother was eventually revealed to
be tarbauti the queen of the frost
giants and she supposedly killed herself
after being so ashamed for giving birth
to a runt cross giant because frost
giants are usually super tall they're
giants and loki was very small which is
why loki is the same size of the
asgardian hopefully we'll see more about
loki's biological mother in like the
second season of loki because i i was
really convinced that our body was going
to show up yeah he is loki because we're
going we're talking about a show about
loki's life it is in his past and all
that stuff so yeah they never really
talk about his biological mother i mean
i think that that's gotta i think season
two baby that's a scoop that's gotta
happen and we also don't know who
sylvie's biological mother is so it's
possible that sylvie's mother is not the
far bouti variant of her timeline it
could be another frost giant entirely
laufey is presumably the one with the
royal bloodline so in that way the loki
mothers in these universes could be
interchangeable so whatever defect that
caused loki and sylvie to not be born a
full frost giant could be passed down
through the father's side of the family
lydia and it could also be some curse
placed on laufey by some magical being
that he's sincerely pissed off he's a
real uh freezy [ __ ] that loudly but
either way the chance that loki and
sylvie could have different biological
mothers instead of similar variant
mothers means that their genetics could
be even more dissimilar but it's also
interesting to note here that the comics
actually switched the genders of loki's
parents from what they were in real
norse mythology in norse myth laufey is
the name of loki's mother farbadi
disowned loki for some reason i don't
know i mean it was probably because loki
was an [ __ ] so he carried his
mother's name and it was called laufi
son so why the hell did the comic switch
this who the hell knows but one more
important thing to consider is that loki
and silvie are not brother and sister
there are variants from different
dimensions so you might be thinking well
that makes them like identical twins
right well identical tins happen when a
single fertilized egg splits into two
and the twins then share a genetic
makeup though it's not a 100 identical
genetic makeup also identical twins are
always the same sex and there are so
many random variations that can happen
when the genetic materials of a male and
a female are combined to make a new
human like loki and sylvie are not twins
they have completely different genetic
makeups so here as we arrive at the end
of this conversation this incestuous
discussion i think we can definitively
say that while loki and sylvie's pairing
certainly breaks the laws of you know
interdimensional stability it's
definitely not incest and their genetic
makeups are so completely different and
their dna from different universes that
the incest label does not apply here
if anything the trait of loki's loving
themselves more than anyone else
probably explains why loki and sylvie
have such strong feelings for each other
like they share similar qualities and
understand each other's struggles but
they are two completely different people
though if they were to make an offspring
it should 100 percent be a nexus being
because yeah good god that that's
that'll probably be a very uh
mischievous child the prince of mischief
would you guys want to see a loki
sylvie baby let us know in the comments
below
[Laughter]
straight up like that's literally that's
probably the the true joker origin story
but a great way for you and any of your
variants to support new rock stars is by
checking out our merch at new
rockstarsmerch.com so be sure to check
out our most recent addition to our
latest obsession line of shirts inspired
by the suicide squad it's an amazing
shirt you gotta check it out i love the
suicide squad it's kind of it's amazing
i love it but we've only got a limited
supply of these left so be sure to grab
one before the tiny bomb inside your
brain explodes we didn't put it there
it's just it was there before when we
when we found it uh it's a great way to
support the channel and all of our
awesome content that we produce so head
on over and check out all of our merch
options over at
newrockstarsmerge.com.gov.com
and before we dive into our bite size
questions next some words from the
amazing folks that help bring big
question to you folks like mint mobile
because after years of fine print
contracts and getting ripped off by big
wireless providers those motherf um i
can't say bad words in the ad we've all
learned that there's always a catch the
cool thing about mint mobile is that
there is no catch mobile secret sauce is
that they're the first company to sell
wireless service online only by cutting
out retail stores there's no crazy
overhead costs that get passed down to
you in form of you know stupid mystery
fees instead mint just passes on those
sweet savings directly to you because
they're just nice like that ryan
reynolds owns the company so he's not
going to screw you over you look you
trust deadpool right why wouldn't you
phillip made the switch to mobile and he
loves that he gets to keep his number
and gets better service at a much better
price like he's always talking about i'm
in mobile's amazing right phillip please
i'm i'm at a funeral
[Laughter]
for people looking for extra savings
mint mobile offers premium wireless for
just 15 bucks a month and all plans come
with unlimited talk and text and
high-speed data delivered on the
nation's largest 5g network and if
you're not 100 satisfied mint mobile has
you covered with their seven-day
money-back guarantee switch to mit
mobile and get premium wireless service
starting at just 15 bucks a month so to
get your new wireless plan for just 15
bucks a month and get this plan shipped
to your door for free go to
mintmobile.com
big q that's mint mobile.com
bigq cut your wireless bill to 15 bucks
a month at mintmobile.com bigq and we
also want to thank
honey we all shop online we've all seen
that promo code field taunt us at
checkout but thanks to honey manually
searching for coupon codes is a thing of
the past honey is a free shopping tool
that scours the internet for promo codes
and applies the best ones and puts it in
your cart honey supports over 30 000
stores online all of your favorites too
many to name but i'm guessing they're
ones that you like when you're shopping
online go to check out the honey button
drops down and all you have to do is
click apply coupons it's that easy wait
a few seconds as honey searches for
coupons that could find for that site if
honey finds a working coupon you'll
watch those prices crash baby faster
than me trying to finish a term paper at
midnight when it's due the next day
crashing why because i won't borrow my
roommates adderall i'm not going to go
down that path okay too real too real
did i just get a little too real for you
guys off-screen producer brandon who is
drug-free as far as we know recently
used honey
to save 18
on some new work clothes in case we make
him start coming back into the office
again and by the way brandon i want to
stress this you do still need to buy
pants too just because you buy a nice
dress shirt doesn't mean you can go
bottomless although
maybe we'll push for casual fridays
honey has found it's over 17 million
members over 2
billion with a b dollars in savings if
you don't already have honey you could
be straight up missing out on free
savings it's literally free that
installs in just a few seconds and by
getting it you're doing yourself a solid
as well as new rock stars and we love
that that's a that's a symbiotic
relationship i'd never recommend
something i don't use get honey for free
at joinhoney.com
big question that's join honey dot com
slash big question i love you all right
well as we go on to our bite size
question i was thinking with with
obi-wan coming forward i've been
thinking a lot about obi-wan in his life
you know how when obi-wan was a padawan
with with little with qui guan jin and
they were just going on little
adventures together so that made me
think
of this bite-sized question that was
submitted by i aj smith on discord how
long does it take a padawan to become a
master jedi great question great
question iaj training
to become a jedi is a personal journey
of meditation and learning of course as
well as doing everything you can to not
turn to the dark side of the force even
though it looks like way more fun and
you get to bang girls or guys or
whatever you want the training path for
a jedi is supposed to start when you're
fairly young at least that's how it was
in the old republic before order 66. you
remember that fun times once it was
determined that you have the force you
were whisked away to the jedi temple to
begin your training as a young ling he
killed the younglings anakin is this
true
i did what i had to do
you remember when anakin made a young
julian salad out of them over uh over
there that was nice oh yeah sliced and
diced surprisingly brittle that's right
they were
so tender at that age he made a nice
little youngling charcuterie board uh
those were younglings that's what we
were talking about the first step on the
jedi training path once you reach a
certain age and are ready for combat
you can build a lightsaber and become a
padawan that's if you haven't been
viciously murdered by then you would
then be given a more experienced jedi to
be your mentor this could be a jedi
knight or a higher ranking jedi master
not anakin though
got him
never anakin always getting pissed and
dismissed if you'll remember
in the prequel film the phantom menace
one of the finest films of all time oh
yes
obi-wan was still a padawan to jedi
master qui-gon jinn to rank up from
padawan to jedi knight you have to
complete the jedi trials once you're at
night you could spend some more time
training and honing your skills and
possibly mentoring a padawan of your
choice you were the chosen one
eventually if the jedi grand master saw
fit you would be given the title of jedi
master there's really no set timeline
for when you move from youngling to
padawan to knight to eventually jedi
master it's based on your own abilities
for example obi-wan was still a padawan
in his early 20s some people fail to
launch look at mcconaughey
however anakin moves much faster through
the ranks during his training possibly
due to his increased forced abilities
and also probably because there was uh
some heavy duty clone wars going on also
he probably took adderall he definitely
anakin for sure took adderall obi-wan
was like i'm just gonna drink a bang
energy look at that naming a sponsor
so i can take anywhere from a few years
if you're someone like luke skywalker to
an entire lifetime to go from padawan to
jedi master patience use the force think
but if you want on the fast track you
should probably wait until there's an
intergalactic war going on because the
jedi master is going to let their guard
down then and just start promoting
[ __ ]
that's it that's your answer your
bronies go home well thank you tommy
your answers are always so informative
but i got another one for you okay sit
back and relax just yet because never
got another one you ready you ready
which of the olympic sports would each
of the original six avengers be the best
at we'll look at both the original six
avengers in the comics as well as the
original six avengers in the mcu and
let's assume
that the olympic committee is not going
to let you bring any special equipment
to the events you have to go on pure
talent alone tony wouldn't be able to
use his armored suit gear so he'd have
to aim for the events where his
intellect gives him the upper hand tony
could probably learn everything there is
to know about sailing and probably be
one of the best there is that's a rich
man sport when did you become an expert
in sailing last night
we'll say sailing for tony let's say
sailing that's a good one he just looks
good on a boat i i must say he does
especially when he's uh saving people on
a fairy yes he looks especially good
it's a great look for him
all right next we have
ants
ant-man and here we're talking hank pym
ant-man so he doesn't get his ant-man
suit he can't rely on that and until
drinking becomes an olympic sport he
should probably just stick to
hand-to-hand combat skills which he does
have so we'll say
boxing or judo for hank pym
troubled soul hank pin all right
next hulk let's assume that if bruce
hulked out he'd be disqualified so
we wouldn't want him killing anyone so
the hulk should focus on the commerce
olympic sport that there is
golf could you imagine that bruce banner
golfing get like the hulk with like a
normal sized putting stick also calmest
olympic sport there is golf i've never
seen more white men lose their [ __ ] than
on a golf course uh except for maybe uh
maybe at a tgi
got him so you're spinning straight
backs tommy too real all right next we
have thor thor would probably excel at
most olympic events but let's be honest
he needs to do track and field solely
for the hammer throw but he'd probably
win all the track and field events uh
and i don't even know if he could win
the hammer throw because he could throw
that thing around the world can't he
they'd just be like zero you threw it
the entire it just came all the way back
around
next we have wasp janet van dyne
wouldn't have her suit as we've already
discussed
she's a natural she has natural combat
abilities thanks to the training she
received from both her husband hank and
captain america so she should also
compete in boxing judo karate maybe even
wrestling a little grappling huh i'd pay
money to watch michelle pfeiffer russell
so next we've got captain america cap's
got a lot of natural ability that they
can't take away from him thanks to the
super soldier serum he'd probably be
pretty adept at any singles competition
and would probably help any team he was
part of win a medal as well he should
run the marathon do the decathlon and
pentathlon basically probably join
america's rugby team wrestling for sure
rowing uh the swimming events basketball
seriously just sign cap up for every
event he's not gonna not have the
stamina before seriously he can
literally do probably like two events at
the same time that man is juiced up
that's right let's look at the mcu
avengers lineup we've already covered
iron man hulk thor and captain america
that will all stay the same but we've
got hawkeye which is of course
curling
i'm kidding it's archery obviously but
really
we're gonna be good at any event that
requires target position shooting table
tennis even badminton would be a good
event for hawker then we have uh black
widow and her uh
she would be tied up in litigation so
she would not be able to compete no i'm
just kidding definitely put black widow
in the combat fighting events like judo
boxing and taekwondo but we should also
remember that she has some dance
training so throw her in rhythmic
gymnastics just in case and that's it
yo i feel like black widow would be an
amazing uh figure skater yeah this is
not the winter olympics but like she
would kill it with figure skating
absolutely all right well thank you mr
thomason for these amazing answers to
these amazing questions that we've got
please join our discord if you want to
ask big questions like these and you
make sure to use the hashtag bigquestion
i'm on twitter if you want to submit big
questions and stuff because that's how
we do it but yeah let us move on to our
favorite segment of the show it's the
box of scraps box of scraps
so today's box of scraps question is
tommy if you were on the suicide squad
what would be your useless power
i would be a
like uh blob like structure
like just like melting person but uh uh
my name would be the grammar slob uh and
i would be
i would be able to go around
basically on a scooter
scooting my big blobby body around
correcting people between uh there there
and there
which and which and uh you know i before
e except after c the grammar
when you use the oxford combo when you
use a regular comma when you use an
ellipse when do you use uh you know all
that stuff a semicolon a colon all that
stuff that's what i would be good at
proofreading i dig it i like it
the grammar
wow i feel like you would uh all the
english like majors um english
professors uh school teachers would all
us co-sign this yeah they would all
bring their kids to watch the suicide
squad
at that point absolutely oh god
but that's a really good one um my
useless power i think i'd probably end
up just being a comic book guy from the
simpsons be like because i have all this
comic knowledge in my head i'll just be
like um actually uh
hakkai was only running temporarily
thank you very much
so some [ __ ] like that i don't know just
like
hopefully not as obnoxious and annoying
as comic book guy for the simpsons but
like you know just a useless comic book
novel because i feel like i know so much
about obscure marvel [ __ ] that i'm just
like all right might as well make that
into a power maybe amanda waller used me
to like infiltrate a comic-con or
something i don't know
perfect but that is it for this episode
of big question i want to thank tommy
for joining me as always you can follow
him at tommy beck told he's hilarious
he's funny please follow him on twitter
he's the coolest man alive you can
follow me at mastertainment after you're
done following tommy but most
importantly most importantly you can
follow us at the rockstars wherever we
are on the internet and if you follow us
on youtube make sure to hit that
notification bell so you can get
notifications whenever we upload a video
and please make sure to hit up new
rockstarsmerch.com because we have
amazing shirts like this and all sorts
of cool [ __ ] over there that'll make you
look cooler uh than you already are so
please head on over there because it
really helps us out thank you guys so
much for watching and we will see you
guys next time we love you so much
goodbye
[Music]
you